[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Hello, and welcome
to the tenth episode of the
weekly Google Cloud Platform
Podcast.
I am Francesc.
And I'm here with Mark.
Mark Mandel.
How are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I'm good.
How are you doing, Francesc?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Pretty good.
Pretty good.
Just getting very excited
about this episode.
We're going to be talking
with some of our good friends,
Google developer experts.
MARK MANDEL: Some good
friends in Australia.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: It
makes me very happy.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So we're
going to be interviewing them
about GD-- what is a
Google Developer expert?
What do they do?
And how do you become one?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
And even talk a little bit
more about Big Data and some
of our tooling in
that area, too,
and how some of our
actual users are using it,
and the use cases they
have. [INAUDIBLE].
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
That's really the kind of people
I really enjoyed talking to
is people that are using our
technologies for things that we
didn't even expect,
because that's
how you learn how to improve
your products, really.
So very, very useful people.
MARK MANDEL: Definitely.
And if anyone's out
there using our products
and want to come on
the podcast, please
don't hesitate to
get in contact.
We'd love to speak to you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Should we do the--
MARK MANDEL: Do the thing?
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
--contact method?
MARK MANDEL: What's
the email address?
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
The email address
is hello@gcppodcast.com.
MARK MANDEL: On Reddit?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It's
the subreddit slash-- no.
r/gcppodcast.
MARK MANDEL: On Twitter?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: #gcppodcast.
MARK MANDEL: The website?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: gcppodcast.com.
MARK MANDEL: And Google+?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: +Google
Cloud Platform podcast.
MARK MANDEL: You can actually
go to google.com/+Gcppodcast,
and it works.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: There you go.
OK.
I almost got it this time.
MARK MANDEL: There we go.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Good, so yeah.
If you have any like,
let's do it again.
If someone wants
to send us emails
about cool things of the week,
questions, or topics that you'd
like us to cover, whatever.
We always like receiving
emails from you people.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
It makes this job fun.
So we definitely
want to hear it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful.
So we have a great cool
thing of the week this week.
I'm pretty excited
about this one.
It's coming up in March.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I'm between
excited and slightly scared,
because a lot of work
coming on for this trip.
We're going to be-- we actually
just announced the next
GCP Next.
The next GCP Next.
MARK MANDEL: The next GCP Next.
Yeah.
That's good.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's
a good way of putting it.
So GCP Next, which is the Google
Cloud Platform big event taking
place in San Francisco.
Pier 48, if I'm not mistaken.
And it's going to be
on March 23 and 24.
MARK MANDEL: Yes, it is.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
what is this about?
MARK MANDEL: So it's the big
Google Cloud Platform event.
So if you're interested
in Google Cloud Platform,
and you want to come
down and meet the DAs,
meet the developer advocates,
meet the engineers,
I'm sure they're probably
also just as exciting.
Project managers.
Yep.
Here probably I'm
guessing there are
going to be some
exciting announcements.
I can confirm nothing.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, there's
completely confidential things
like-- nah.
Just kidding.
Nah, but there's going
to be really cool stuff.
I know I'm very excited
about the keynotes.
Also because we're going to
have some really cool people
at the keynote.
We have-- Urs is
going to be speaking.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Also Diane.
So yeah.
Basically--
MARK MANDEL: Brian Stevens.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Brian Stevens.
So the top people from
Google Cloud Platform
are going to be there for you.
So I think it's an
opportunity not to miss.
MARK MANDEL: Jeff Dean's
going to be there.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Yeah.
Jeff Dean.
Yeah, he's kind of
important I guess.
MARK MANDEL: A little bit,
just a smidge, you know.
That's fine.
But yeah.
We're going to running like
a GCP boot camp the day
before, as well, so a full-day
instructor-led training.
Yeah, we'll definitely have
a link in the show notes.
But yeah, if you have
anything interesting
you want to hear about
Google Cloud Platform,
and you want to sort of mingle
with people who are also
doing Google Cloud
Platform things,
GCP Next is the event to get to.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I know I'm going to be there.
Actually, we're
going to be there.
We're planning on recording
a special episode--
our first episode
outside of the studio.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Yeah.
So if you're interested
in being in the podcast
but don't want to
do a lot of work,
if you're physically at the
event, we will be around.
And we'll be looking to
interview people at the event.
So please definitely come
up to us and say hello.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Cool.
OK.
So that was our cool
thing of the week.
Now I guess time to go say hi
to our friends in Australia.
MARK MANDEL: Let's talk to
our friends in Australia.
We are joined today by the very
first Google Developer experts
to be coming on air
with us on the podcast.
I'm very excited, also
because both of them
live in my hometown of
Melbourne, Australia, which
makes me double as excited.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: We are joined
today by Graham Polley and Pablo
Caif, which I think I just
messed up your last name.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, it's Caif.
MARK MANDEL: The both of you.
Both of you.
How do you pronounce
your last name,
so that people know
how to get them right?
PABLO CAIF: It's Caif.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It's easy.
If you speak Spanish, it's easy.
PABLO CAIF: It's Spanish,
it's easy, of course.
GRAHAM POLLEY: And it's Polley.
It's Polley as in
Polly wants a cracker.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
What's even worse is I
asked you beforehand,
and then messed it up in
exactly the [INAUDIBLE].
So thank you.
Thank you so much
for joining us.
Like I said, you're both
Google Developer experts.
I know you've been in the
program for a little while.
You're both down in
Melbourne, Australia,
which makes me super happy.
Eenie meanie minie mo.
Graham, you're on
our document first.
Why don't you give
us a little bit
of background about yourself--
you know, who you are,
what you do.
And then we'll get to Pablo.
GRAHAM POLLEY: Sure.
So first of all, thanks for
having us do the podcast.
We're also very
excited to do it.
My name's Graham Polley.
And I'm a software engineer, and
also Google Developer expert,
as you've pointed out already.
And I'm actually a
Google Developer expert
for Cloud Platform.
And I specialize in big data.
So work a lot with tools like
BigQuery, Cloud Dataflow,
Dataproc, google cloud
Storage, and also
the usual compute engine
type things as well.
And I'm based down in Melbourne.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
What about you, Pablo?
PABLO CAIF: Yeah.
So I'm also very
happy to be here.
And I'm a Google
Developer expert,
same as Graham, for the Google
Cloud Platform and software
engineer as well, been working
in the field for something
like 13 years.
Done a few things like mobile
development, web development.
But lately, I've been
mostly specializing
in big data and all
this sort of stuff.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
You are Google
developer experts.
Could you tell us a little
bit first of all for how long,
and how you became
Google Developer experts?
But also, what is it?
What is being a Google
Developer expert?
Maybe Graham can start.
GRAHAM POLLEY: Sure.
Yeah.
Sure.
So both myself
and Pablo, we came
on board as Google Developer
experts around the same time--
actually at the same time.
That would have been about
three months ago now.
So we're fairly
new to the program.
And what it means is we're
recognized by Google.
There is about I believe
250 of us worldwide.
So we're recognized
for our expertise
in a specific area of Google
technology as their products.
In our case, it's
Google Cloud Platform.
We do a lot of blogging.
We go and talk at conferences.
We help the local community.
We help startups.
We do mentoring.
And we also get a yearly trip.
Once a year, we get to meet
all the other Google Developer
experts, which is really cool.
This year it was
in Mountain View
just last month,
which is really cool.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
I saw you guys there.
GRAHAM POLLEY: Yeah.
We get direct access to the
engineering teams as well.
So we get early access to builds
and features and new products
and stuff like that.
And we can reach out directly
to the engineering teams.
And that's a huge help
for us, especially when
we're using the products.
We can talk to the engineering
lead teams directly.
It's awesome.
And we also get foresight
into product roadmaps
and that kind of thing.
So that's being a
Google Developer expert.
And then the journey
about how we actually
became Google Developer experts
is quite an interesting one.
So myself and Pablo, we
were doing a lot of work
with BigQuery.
And we were just blown
away by how cool it was
and how much data we
could smash through.
And we wrote a blog about it.
And that blog got picked
up by our good friend
Philippe Hoffa, who I believe
you guys know quite well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
We interviewed him
two episodes ago.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
something like that.
GRAHAM POLLEY: Ah,
two episodes ago.
Yeah.
Cool.
So.
Yeah, Philippe's a great guy.
And he actually
picked up our blog.
He found our blog.
And he shared it internally.
And then it actually went-- It
made its way up to Urs Holzle,
who then re-shared
it on his G+ page.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
GRAHAM POLLEY: And
then from there
it just kind of snowballed.
And then we started
doing more blogs.
And then what actually happened
was the Dataflow team--
so Google Cloud Dataflow
team reached out to us.
And they said, look.
We've got this new
product in beta.
It's called Cloud Dataflow.
We think it would be
pretty cool for you guys
to be beta testers on it.
So we said, yeah, absolutely.
And we jumped in.
We started playing with it.
We gave them feedback.
And then after that,
the product manager
for Google Cloud Dataflow, a
guy called Rafael Fernandez,
he then nominated us to become
Google Developer experts.
And that's the key to being
a Google Developer expert.
You have to be nominated
by a Google employee.
So once you're nominated
by a Google employee,
then you do an application.
So myself and Pablo did that.
And then you go through
a round of interviews.
They make sure you really
know what you're doing
and you really know what
you're talking about.
And then you finally get
accepted to the program.
And that's pretty
much the journey
of how we became Google
Developer experts.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: So Pablo,
you've been relatively quiet.
Why don't you tell us a
little bit about the work
you do at Shine, the tools you
use, and how they go together,
and what you're up to?
PABLO CAIF: Yes.
So first of all, Shine
is a software consultancy
based in Melbourne.
And we do a lot of
work with Big Data.
Our main client is Telstra.
Yeah.
It's one of the largest ISP.
And we'll talk a
little bit later
about more in-depth about the
stuff we've been doing there.
But basically, we need to enter
in just tons and tons of Atom
logs and process them.
We use a whole combination
of stuff between Google Cloud
Platform tools and a
bit of AWS as well.
Basically, the idea is to
help them to understand
all the data they're
using to basically get
like useful insights to all
the information they have.
MARK MANDEL: That's very cool.
That's very cool.
So I think one of
the highlights for me
when actually I
probably got to know you
and Graham from Shine
Technology and stuff,
was the blog post about the
17-minute train challenge.
GRAHAM POLLEY: Oh, yes.
MARK MANDEL: Which I
thought was quite exciting.
Do you want to
tell our listeners
a little bit about that,
and how that came to be.
And I mean, even like where
did that idea come from?
GRAHAM POLLEY: Yeah, sure.
So I take the train to work.
And I was sitting on
the train coming in.
I was reading, as you
do, the tech news.
And something popped
up in my feed.
And it was Google have announced
a new product called Dataproc.
I went oh, that
looks kind of cool.
So I started reading about it.
And I was actually chatting with
Pablo at the same time on IM.
We just got to talking about it.
And then one of the things
in the announcemen--
I think it was on the
Google Cloud Platform
blog-- it was, we can
spin up a Hadoop or Spark
cluster in under 90 seconds.
And I thought, wow.
That's a bold claim.
That's a really bold claim.
And we got to thinking.
And we thought, let's vet that.
Let's see if it
really can do that.
So we came up with the idea
of could we actually spin up
a Hadoop/Spark cluster using
Dataproc in the time it takes
for my train to
depart Melbourne City
and get home to my last stop.
But not only that, so we thought
that was a little bit easy.
We also threw a few
curve balls into the mix.
So it would have to
spin up the cluster.
My train commute is 17 minutes.
So it would have to
spin up the cluster.
It would have to be able
to run a Hadoop job.
to run Apache Spark job.
And I should also be
able to SSH into some
of the nodes in the cluster
and have a play with them,
and use the Cloud
Shell from the browser,
and all that kind of stuff.
And then finally, tear
down the whole cluster
before the train got
into the last station.
So that's really how
the idea came about.
It was just something Pablo
were chatting about it.
We thought it would be really
cool, something original.
And it would actually
be a good way
to see if Dataproc
really was that fast.
Could it really stand up
a cluster that quickly?
And so we did it.
One of the great things
about it is actually we
just tethered it off my phone.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
GRAHAM POLLEY: So we stood
up a Dataproc cluster.
I can't remember, I
think it was 8 nodes
in the cluster, or something
like that all tethering off 4G.
It's crazy.
MARK MANDEL: I do see
here that you didn't quite
complete the challenge.
You got very close, though.
GRAHAM POLLEY: Got
very, very close.
So I was pulling into
the last station.
And I had initiated a
shutdown of the cluster.
And unfortunately, the cluster
just didn't shut down in time.
So I got to spin it up.
I got to run a Hadoop job.
I got to run a spark job.
SSH into some of the nodes.
But the cluster just
didn't come down
in the time it needed
before I got home.
But I marked it
down as a success.
MARK MANDEL: So it was deleting.
It was in the process.
GRAHAM POLLEY: It was in the
process of deleting, exactly.
I think I missed it
by about 30 seconds.
MARK MANDEL: There you go.
GRAHAM POLLEY: Seriously.
So yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Was it recorded?
I'd have loved to see that as
a video of seeing you panicking
and trying to stop the cluster
right before the train's
arriving into the station.
GRAHAM POLLEY: Yeah.
So unfortunately,
it wasn't recorded.
Didn't have the
foresight for that one.
Did do a blog post about it.
So you're more than
welcome to read the blog.
And it's got
screenshots in there.
And it was a very uber
scientific challenge,
as you can tell.
Jump on the train,
tether a phone,
spin up a Dataproc cluster.
But one of the things
that I failed to consider,
or that we failed to
consider before we
did it was that there's black
spots on the train with 4G.
So every now and then,
I'd lose my connection
and I'd lose my SSH session.
And like, panic, panic,
panic, until my connectivity
came back.
And yeah.
But it was good fun.
It was good fun.
And again, it was the
originality of it as well.
And the blog post got
quite a lot of attention.
And I think it got shared
again internally at Google.
So that's really cool.
And that leads into the
Google Developer expert stuff.
That's the kind of
stuff we do as well.
Writing blog posts like that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
And you were saying
that it's not a very
scientific method of comparing
performance.
I have this video
that I really like
of one of the people
from [INAUDIBLE] team,
Brendan Burns, trying to measure
how long it takes to start up
a [INAUDIBLE] cluster,
and comparing it
to how long it takes for
him to prepare a latte.
GRAHAM POLLEY: Oh.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So you know--
PABLO CAIF: Sounds
like a lot of fun.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: It's
entirely scientific.
Entirely.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Entirely
scientific, of course.
MARK MANDEL: All right.
Cool.
So obviously, you're doing
stuff with like Dataproc.
And you're doing stuff
with Big Data and BigQuery.
Do you want to talk a bit more
about the sort of Big Data
problems you're working on.
Obviously, you said you
were talking about analytics
and stuff like that.
But can you talk a bit more
concretely about the stuff
that you're building and
why you chose Google Cloud
Platform and the tools you
have to solve those problems.
PABLO CAIF: So I mentioned
before, we're basically
dealing with tons and
tons of [INAUDIBLE] logs.
What we have come to work on is
basically a statistical model
that analyzes all those
logs, which is developed
by a veteran, not a scientist.
And that's the main
beat we actually
started using Dataflow for--
all the sort of ETL work
and the actual statistical
model implementation,
each one of the steps.
And we found that it was
very helpful in that aspect.
And we also use
BigQuery, of course,
to store all these
huge mound of data.
And we can run queries
pretty quickly,
like go through
terabytes of data
in a matter of seconds, which
I remember at the beginning,
left a few people
very, very astonished
about all this stuff.
Like wow, I can't
believe-- you're
telling me you can actually
run query terabytes of data
in 15 seconds?
Yeah.
But with Oracle, it takes
like-- I don't know-- one hour,
you know.
And then when they
were seeing it,
they were like, oh,
I can't believe this.
MARK MANDEL: So I'm curious.
What's the largest data set that
you've put through big query?
GRAHAM POLLEY: So yeah.
So I think the amount of
data that we have [INAUDIBLE]
is what do we have?
So we're doing about 5
billion rows a month.
That's what we were
ingesting into BigQuery.
Is that right, Pablo?
About 5 billion rows a month.
And then we've run queries
over several years.
So we've gone up to
about 100 billion rows.
And it was about 15 terabytes.
PABLO CAIF: Yeah.
It's difficult, because we've
got several projects going on.
So you sort of need
to get on all of them.
But I think something like that.
So for us, it's
quite a lot of data.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
PABLO CAIF: A lot of data.
And so what sort of things are
you providing for the customer?
Obviously you said, like
statistical models and stuff.
You're helping them with things?
PABLO CAIF: Yes.
So basically we have implemented
all these statistical model.
Then they use like BI
tools to access to that.
So all the results
of running the model
get stamped into big query.
And we also have been
trying to help them lately
to understand how Dataflow
works, because it's always
good for them to get a very good
understanding of how they can
optimize the
algorithms so they can
work much better in this
Dataflow programming model.
And we also been giving a few
technical talks about big query
and data flow to help them
understand the advantages
you can get when using the
Google Cloud Platform products.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It seems like
you've basically been working
on Big Data for quite a while.
And you've been
blogging about it.
And thanks to just
blogging, you ended up
becoming one of our GDs.
What is your advice
for other people
that want to become a GD?
GRAHAM POLLEY: Yeah.
That's a really good question.
So I would say it's
a very good program.
At least I can speak
for myself and say,
I'm happy in the program.
And what I like most about
it, like I touched on earlier,
would be getting direct access
to the engineering teams.
That's just awesome.
Like last month we were
over in San Francisco
attending the GDE summit, which
is that yearly event that I
talked about, where we all come
together for a couple of days.
But around that we
actually went out
and we met the-- myself
and Pablo went and met all
the Dataflow engineering teams.
And we sat with them.
And we discussed how we used
the tool and the product.
And that was really cool.
And they actually sat with us.
And they actually
did a code review.
So the tech lead for
data flow reviewed
our code-- Frances Parry.
That was just unparalleled
in terms of awesomeness.
And she was like, you could
do some optimization here,
performance enhancements
here, and change this,
and it'd be a little
bit more modular.
We were like, oh my god, trying
to actually code while she
was telling us this stuff.
And then after that,
we went up and we
met the Dremel and BigQuery
engineering teams in Seattle.
Like, that's just cool, right?
Where you can sit with these
guys, and talk to them,
and talk to engineers,
being engineers
ourselves, about how
these tools work.
They don't give up all the
juicy details of course,
of how, for example, Dremel
works under the hood.
But we were privy
to some information
that not a lot of
people would get.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Gotcha.
That's very cool.
GRAHAM POLLEY: And that's
one thing I particularly
like about the program.
The second part-- how do
people get into the program
if they are interested.
It would really be getting
your name out there.
So start off doing blogging.
Go to your local GDG
group in your city.
So most cities will
have a GDG, which
is Google Developer Group.
That's officially
sponsored by Google.
Going to the meetups.
Chatting with the guys and
girls at those meetups.
And then if you're
really, really
keen to get into the
program, you really
got to make that connection
with someone in Google,
or be nominated.
That's the only way to get in.
And I think that's
a good system,
because that's the way Google
really get good people in.
It's if you're nominated.
So yeah.
My advice would be
just to get publicity,
and to get your name out
there blogging, doing talks.
Because like you
don't have to be a GDE
to go out and do this stuff.
You can go out and do this
stuff without being a GDE.
Right.
So you can give a talk
at a local meetup.
Or you can write
a blog on BigQuery
or [INAUDIBLE] or
Dataflow or Dataproc.
You don't have to be a GDE.
And then if it's a good blog
and it's got good content,
I'm sure will be
picked up by someone.
At least that's how
it started for us.
So I hope that
answers your question.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
That sounds like
very good advice.
I hadn't thought about
Google Developer Group.
But that's a great
place to start.
GRAHAM POLLEY: Yeah.
That would be in the
first place I'd start.
PABLO CAIF: Yeah.
So for me, again,
it's pretty much
pretty similar to what
Graham saying, said before.
In terms of meeting
the engineers for me
was the top of the--
the cherry on the pie.
And it was really exciting.
Get to talk to them, to the
people who actually have
been developing
the tools we used,
know them from top to bottom.
I was very privileged to have
also the leader, Frances Parry,
reviewing my slide deck.
I was giving a talk
in the depth test.
And she sat with me.
We went through
all the slide deck.
She started giving
me recommendations
about how to present different
things and stuff like that.
And for me, that was
really, really exciting.
And it was a privilege.
To answer the second
part of the question,
I know this is pretty much
what also Graham said,
in terms of if you're really
keen on getting into the expert
program, you need to
make visible yourself
in terms of writing
blogs or participating
in Google Developer groups,
giving talks, if you can.
That's always good.
Trying to present stuff,
talk about the technology.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Sounds good.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
We'll wrap up soon.
But is there anything
else you wanted
to maybe discuss or bring up
or plug, or anything like that?
PABLO CAIF: Check out our blog.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We'll put
the link on the show notes.
That's for sure.
MARK MANDEL: Definitely.
GRAHAM POLLEY: Beautiful.
Pablo?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: You
mentioned that it
was important to be out there,
give talks, go to conferences.
Where can we find you?
Are you going to
any conferences?
PABLO CAIF: Yeah.
We applied for a few talks.
There is one coming up
in London about big data.
At the moment it hasn't
been confirmed yet.
There's also the coming
Google Cloud Platform
event now in March in San Fran.
We also applied for that one.
But we also give some talks
in the local developer groups.
So I myself giving
a talk at the end
of February about data flow in
the GDG group her in Melbourne.
I think we can add the details
about the event in the notes.
MARK MANDEL: Definitely.
Graham, was there anything else?
GRAHAM POLLEY: No.
Just the usual stuff.
Twitter, myself and Pablo
are really active on Twitter.
And we have some pretty
cool conversations
with people like
Philippe and Frances
and all those guys in the US.
So you can get us
on Twitter any time.
I'm sure my Twitter handle
will be made public,
and Pablo's too.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
GRAHAM POLLEY: Like
Pablo said, we've
got a few talks, talk
proposals in the pipeline.
The biggest one that
I'm most excited about,
which Pablo just touched,
would be the GCP Next.
And that's in March.
Now unfortunately,
I've got a baby
on the way on the exact due
date is the exact same day.
So it's the March 23.
Pablo will be
heading over to that.
And hopefully--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Congratulations
on that, by the way.
GRAHAM POLLEY:
Thank you very much.
It's going to be a first baby.
So the storm is about
to arrive at my doorstep
in about nine weeks.
Well, fingers crossed.
That would be really
cool if we actually
got to speak at GCP
Next, which is--
MARK MANDEL: We have
no control over that.
But some people who may listen
to the podcast, may listen,
may have been told.
GRAHAM POLLEY: That's not what
I was hinting at all in any way
whatsoever.
So what will be will be.
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful.
Well, thank you very
much for joining us.
I think we're going
to have to wrap it
up there for time's sake.
I'm sure we could
talk for hours on end.
But yeah.
Thanks so much for joining us.
It's been an absolute pleasure.
GRAHAM POLLEY:
Thank you very much.
PABLO CAIF: Yeah.
And--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Likewise.
Thank you very much.
PABLO CAIF: Looking forward to
reading your future blog posts.
MARK MANDEL: Indeed.
Yeah.
Well, we'll talk
to you maybe then.
Thanks again to Graham
and Pablo for joining us.
Really good conversation.
Enjoy getting outside of Google
people to come in and speak.
It's always great fun.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
That was a very
fun conversation.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
So moving on to the
question of the week.
Francesc, I believe you
have a question today.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I
do have a question.
And it's actually coming
from a couple of people
that I've met before.
There's a lot of people that try
to do things like integration
tests or even
continuous integration,
when what you're trying to
do is to deploy continuously.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And deploying
continuously, it's pretty hard.
There is ways of doing it.
But you know, there's
a skill there.
Then there's deploying
continuously to App Engine.
And all of a sudden, it doesn't
sound that easy anymore,
because you have to use G cloud.
And there's a bunch
of things that you
have to integrate,
authentication, and so on.
So the question was,
like, is there an easy way
to do deployment swap engine?
MARK MANDEL: Like
say, programmatically?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
As part of the script,
something that's
going to be happening
very regularly.
MARK MANDEL: So I got shown
this not too long ago.
And I found it quite exciting.
There is an API
that we have that
enables you to programmatically
deploy to App Engine.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: It's really cool.
It's both a REST
API and a gRPC API.
So you have a choice,
whichever one you want to use.
It's pretty cool.
You can upload your
content-- like so
basically your resources up
into Google Cloud Storage.
You send up a JSON manifest
file to tell App Engine hey,
this is where my stuff is.
This is how I want to deploy it.
This is where I want it to go.
And then it goes off
and does its thing.
And then there's also stuff
in there for like switching
modules.
So which modules
you want to go to.
And like also doing your
standard versioning stuff too.
Like, I want 50% of my
traffic to go to this one.
Or 10%, or 100%.
Yeah.
And also introspection.
You can also do
introspection through it too.
Like, what have I got running.
What versions do I have?
What apps do I have?
It's pretty neat.
I was actually really
impressed with it.
So if you're looking at doing
like continuous delivery
type of stuff, and you want to
be able to push to App Engine,
this looks like a really
good way of doing it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
That sounds really cool.
I could definitely
see it as something
integrated early with Jenkins or
Travis or something like that.
So basically as long as
you have a new file that
has changed, everything,
you get a bunch of tests.
It gets deployed somewhere.
And then someone can
just go and verify
that everything's working.
MARK MANDEL: So I'm
actually thinking
we should do this
for the podcast,
because right now every
Wednesday we manually push it
up.
If we had a service that built
it, push it up to App Engine
every Wednesday, like at
10:00 AM or 8:30 or something.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
you were proposing
using Google technology to
help your Google cloud platform
podcast?
MARK MANDEL: Yes, I am.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Crazy.
MARK MANDEL: This would actually
make my life a lot easier,
rather than getting up
at 7:30 every Wednesday
to push out a podcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I know we're here.
Yeah.
I know.
That sounds like a good idea.
We should try it.
And then open source
the code, of course.
MARK MANDEL: Of course.
Of course.
Wonderful.
All right.
That sounds great.
Well, Francesc, have you got
anything else on your radar?
Obviously, GCP Next will
be coming up for you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So GCP
Next is coming on soon.
But before that, I actually
have a bunch of stuff going on.
So by the end of
this week, I will go
to Belgium for a [INAUDIBLE].
There's going to
be a Go Devroom.
So if you're
around, come say hi.
It's going to be fun.
I'm going to be talking
about the state of Go.
So what is the Go
project doing lately?
It's going to be a
quite interesting talk.
A bunch of new things
in the language,
not really in the language,
but in the tooling.
So I hope that there's going
to be a bunch of people there.
We're going to have
nice conversations.
After that, DevFest in Paris--
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: --where
I'm going to talk
about gRPC and [INAUDIBLE].
MARK MANDEL: Sweet.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I think
that the name of the talk
may be at the end, Building
Micro Services like a Googler.
MARK MANDEL: Oh.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: I think we
need to get gRPC on here.
I'm getting really
excited about that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We should
definitely talk about gRPC.
We actually just mentioned that.
Yeah, we have like, RPC
references for the admin API.
We should definitely
talk about that.
Maybe next episode.
Who knows?
And that's pretty much
it, I think, for now.
Like, that's in the next month.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Yeah.
That sounds good.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: What about you?
MARK MANDEL: So I will be
at the launch hackathon
on the 26th of February.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Where's that?
MARK MANDEL: That's in San
Francisco, which is good.
Yeah.
I'm not doing too much travel
of my own, which is nice.
So I'll be helping
people hack at that,
and probably getting no sleep.
Very excited about Game
Developers Conference.
I'll be there at the booth
pretty much all the time.
We're looking at doing
some really fun events.
We're having a
developer day for that.
So if you're interested
in Google Cloud Platform,
please check that out.
We'll be doing all
sorts of fun things.
But we'll also be doing some
talks sort of at the booth
as well.
Showing off a few bits
and pieces we've got.
I think we might see
some of our demos, which
would be really cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: But yeah.
I love games.
So I'm super excited about GDC.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I know.
I was last year at GDC.
It was an amazing conference.
So really looking
forward to that.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
It's going be great.
GCP Next.
Obviously I'll be there as well.
And then I'll also be at Strada
helping out with some stuff
there too.
So that'll be good fun.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very nice.
Well, I think that
is enough for today.
MARK MANDEL: Definitely.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
as always, thank you
so much for being here with me.
MARK MANDEL: Thank you very
much for being here with me.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And talk
to you all next week.
MARK MANDEL: See you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]